if you want to win the super bowl you
better have a competent backup
quarterback because sometimes that guy
needs to play and sometimes a guy like a
matt moore needs to come in and win
enough games to allow the chiefs to hold
the number one spot in the
afc playoff tree he was one and one last
year when patrick mahomes was injured
but
as a practical matter two in one because
he came in and won that game over the
denver broncos and you take either of
those wins away and the chiefs are not
the one seed and who knows if they even
get to the super bowl so we're gonna
have a draft chris sims
of the best backup quarterbacks
currently in nfl here is the trivia
question if you get it right you get the
first pick andy dalton started a playoff
game in each of his first four nfl
seasons he was injured in what would
have been number five only three other
quarterbacks have done that since 1950
one is autogram
name one of the other two
wow and its first four years as a
starting quarterback his first four
years right
started a playoff game in each of his
first four seasons autogram is one name
one of the other two and they are both
active
oh so i mean i'm gonna say tom brady
does that count or is that not count
because nope nope because he didn't play
his rookie year damn all right well he's
but but they didn't make the playoffs in
2002
right
so you're probably starting to play
yep
all right the answer is russell wilson
and joe flacco
oh wilson i mean wilson has had a
winning record every year of his career
they missed the playoffs one year and
flacco was in the playoffs five straight
years to start his career hey they
wanted you to name both i gave you a
break and that's horrible i should know
both it's just it's amazing how you can
just i just yeah i choked under the
pressure i don't know i mean i should
know that i didn't know that i just
couldn't come up under the time crunch
all right uh i get the board and i tell
you what there are there are other days
where it's better to have the first pick
because this can go in a lot of
different directions but i have to stay
on brand i have to stay true to my form
and true to my beliefs taysom hill is a
backup quarterback of the new orleans
saints and even though he would not be
the game day backup he's got a 21
million dollar contract over the next
two years jameis winston has 1.1 million
for this year that tells you where they
perceive the relative value
when you have a guy who was the best
player on the field for either team in a
playoff game in taysom hill and he is a
backup quarterback on the same step
chart he is the top backup quarterback
in the nfl chris
yeah i it was
i don't know if i would have picked him
one or not it was gonna be really close
but he's certainly on the list here yeah
it's i mean it's it's a it's an
interesting conversation with jason hill
because you know we do see the talent
and all that we just haven't seen him
how to play a whole lot or do anything
you know on a consistent basis but yes
as far as the names that we have listed
here you know i think his ceiling is
about as high as anybody other than
maybe the guy that's on the roster with
him there already in
new orleans now anyways and james
winston so i'm not batting matty you're
picking taysom hill you know yeah he
he's a great backup quarterback and if
he had to come in and be the real backup
quarterback for the new orleans saints
you know i think of course he could be
successful and sean payton's going to
you know scheme up some plays that
really fit what taysom hill does and
accentuate his his values and talents so
it'll be a different type of ball game
all right
man i don't know where i want to go here
but i'm going to have to go with nick
foles as my number one pick i mean when
you're talking about backup quarterbacks
yeah we don't know if he's a starter
you're the best writer how can you how
can you say he's the best backup when by
all indications he's going to be the
starter
we don't know he took a pay cut tough
crap right now he's the backup as we
know
okay
but you know as we've seen of course
this is a guy that's a great backup for
so many reasons one he doesn't have that
big intrusive personality uh he's not
trying to stab the starter in the back
and then of course we know he has the
cool calm collectiveness to come in and
tight situations and perform and he
showed us the ultimate backup you know
uh merit and the fact that he could take
his team to the super bowl if he does
have to come in and be the backup and
not only take him to the super bowl but
win and be clutch in that moment and
because of that i'm going to make it my
first pick
yeah and think back to that super bowl
run it was
nick foles it was case keenum it was tom
brady and who was it was blake bortles
tom brady was the who doesn't belong and
why in that quartet of quarterbacks and
uh that's why look uh i was thinking to
go andy dalton here
but andy dalton never won a playoff game
case keenum did and it was on one of the
most memorable plays we've ever seen in
league history the minneapolis miracle
case keenum
i see a way that the dominoes fall in
cleveland this year
and it's going to take an injury to
baker mayfield to really trigger it
but i could see keenum play very very
well well enough that whatever injury
would open the door for keenum to play
may take a long time to heal they may
want to wait until baker mayfield is
fully and completely 100 because i think
keenum reunited with kevin stefanski
could be every bit as good as he was in
2017 with the vikings so i think case
can and it's not like he's going to come
in and try to take over he's going to
support baker mayfield but i i think
there there is a scenario where we see
plenty of case keenum this year and i
think he would be great if that happened
so give me case keenum for my pick
yeah that's uh i had a feeling i wasn't
sure if you would pull the trigger on
case keenum or not but you know yeah i
think your your his post minnesota
career has made you admire him more you
realize he had a pretty damn good year
that year and um i i
you're you like this new angle with case
keenum and cleveland i i see that it's
the second time you brought it up in the
last two weeks so uh if that happens
holy cow you're gonna be puffing your
chest out big time here all right well
i'm gonna have to go with andy dalton as
my next pick i am you know again i don't
you know yes he's never won a playoff
game
he played in a really tough division as
a starting quarterback for a long long
time and was the starting quarterback
for a very relevant team and one of the
best divisions in football over like a
four or five year span there in the asc
north so andy dalton to me uh yeah he's
one of those guys as a fringe starter if
he's your starter you're sitting there
going oh i think we can get somebody
better uh certainly but if he's your
backup you're going man i don't know if
there's a better backup in football
dalton has starter type ability in some
ways of his game and i think that's
exciting so yeah i think eddie dalton
being you know talented tough battle
tested
he's my guy
and we talk about the value he brings to
the cowboys in the event that they can't
get a deal done with dak prescott by
july 15 and prescott exercises his
prerogative to stay away from training
camp to stay away from the preseason
dalton is the guy who can take over and
replace the starting quarterback and
someone said well why would dak prescott
hold out of training camp in the
preseason if he can't sign a long-term
deal after july 15.
you still can sign a one-year deal with
more money or with a promise that they
won't use the franchise tag on you next
year so there is a reason a business
reason to hold out if you are dak
prescott and you lose no money you you
don't get fined it's okay because you're
not under contract the best backup
quarterbacks in the nfl so far i've got
taysom hill and case keenum chris has
nick foles and andy dalton round three
for me i'm thinking about going back to
the new orleans well chris i'm really
thinking about it but you know what
jameis winston with the 30 interceptions
hey there's a reason he's not a starter
anymore the 30 interceptions i don't
think i can do it i'm gonna go with a
guy who i think fits perfectly what a
backup needs to be especially in this
year of transition
with the new england patriots jimmy
brian hoyer brian hoyer has perfected
the art of being a backup he knows the
josh mcdaniels system he can step in in
a moment's notice and he can help jared
stidham get best prepared to do exactly
what you've been saying you and i are on
the same page on this we may not be on
the same page on a lot of things we're
on the same page on this the patriots
are going to prove that the patriot way
works and the patriot way works by going
next man up with stidum and then
bringing back as they did brian hoyer
who knows that patriot way inside and
out so
look if he was on any other team i
wouldn't have thought about him but on
the patriots it lines up perfectly hoyer
deserves a spot
on this list chris well he i mean yeah
you're right mike i mean he knows that
offense inside it out he saw you know
the greatest person to ever orchestrate
or run that offense do it for a long
long time and tom brady hoyer's played a
ton of football whether that's in
cleveland or san francisco or even last
year with the colts coming in and doing
a solid job it kind of fell off at the
end there but certainly you know again
brian hoyer is one of those guys when
you see him out on the field and you see
him throwing in pre-game warm-ups you go
he's a little bit bigger of a human than
i thought oh man he's got a little
stronger arm than i thought oh he's a
better athlete than i thought so from
that standpoint he is a very good backup
quarterback now i think you missed some
better ones out there
i think i would have taken and i'm going
to take marcus mariota
because marcus mariota i think is a
fringe starting type quarterback and
that'll be my third round pick he has
won some playoff games or won one
playoff game but you know like you said
with brian hoyer too
you know just has the right way about
him as a human and as a as a player and
person to be a good backup like we saw
him last year with the tennessee titans
yeah he got benched but he was the good
soldier sitting there behind ryan
tannehill they infused him into a few
games here and there and you know let
him wet his beak a little bit with
certain plays and had a little package
for him
but i think he's the perfect backup for
any team you know one because he has
athletic ability to rely on he's got
experience he's got size and you know
he's got a lot of other good attributes
again that make him that fringe you know
fringe starting quarterback slash backup
quarterback and football
but i don't think this is the last we
heard of marcus mariota he gets a chance
to play with the raiders and show
something good he might be our starter
once again
yeah and and if not if not because it's
just a one-year deal for mario to seven
and a half million dollars with the
raiders he will be the perfect backup in
2021
if the guy that i picked first ends up
being the starter in new orleans because
you need a backup who can run the
offense that they construct for taysom
hill and i think that mariota of all the
options out there would be the best guy
to come in and be taysom hill's backup
what do you think of that
yes i think it makes a lot of sense it
does you know we talk about this a lot
where if you're going to run a certain
offense you don't want the backup
quarterback to come in the game and all
of a sudden you go oh we can't run the
offense we've been practicing all
through training camp and the first
seven weeks of the season and we have to
change our identity as a football team
you know that makes no sense so yeah
that would make a lot of sense in a lot
of ways and protect a guy like sean
payton to go okay if the wheels did fall
off with a taysom hill or he got injured
you know mariota's got a lot of
experience in big games and knows how to
play the position
other guys i had on my list rg3 who yeah
look he fits the ravens offense i just
don't know what he really has left in
the tank in philly nate sudfeld jalen
hurts i don't know which of the two guys
i would have
but
matt moore's unsigned he's unsigned
damn i didn't realize that i thought he
was still on the chief so i was wrong
there okay
jacob
another one i look at
yeah chad henny and jordan tom who are
the two options in kansas city so i you
know i guess anyone out there who's
looking for a quarterback maybe you want
to give matt moore a call he's available
you know the bengals need one now chris
hey look i know how you feel about blake
bortles but somebody asked me over the
weekend who should the bengals back up
be ryan finley or someone else like well
blake bortles knows that offense because
he was with the rams last year it's the
same offense that zach taylor's running
in cincinnati would you be immortals is
the backup to joe
it would really scare me in the fact
that the rams didn't want to sign blake
bortles that would scare me you know a
one-year deal with a guy who just was in
the afc championship game a few years
ago that would tell me they saw
something this year would go damn if he
gets in the game i'm not so sure i like
our chances so i'm not so sure what
happens with mike bortles
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports